Here's how to play the Mario Kart drinking game.
For this game, you'll need 3 things.
A pack of cheap beer...
2 to 4 players...
and any generation of Mario Kart.
From the new Wii U version, all the way back to Super Nintendo.
Even though we all know N64 is the best.
The rules of the game are simple.
Crack open the beer to start the race.
The first player to cross the finish line wins, but
you must finish your beer before you finish the race.
The only other rule is that your cart must be at a complete stop before you drink your beer.
Because not even Mario tolerates drinking and driving. *Slap*
But you know, drinking right after driving, that's cool.
But don't take our word for how awesome it is.
Here's some people trying out the game for the first time.
Wait, so you drink while you're playing?
So I should just chug it in the beginning?
No.
At least most of it.
That's gonna backfire!
Women: That's a good strategy....  Man: I really want to see you do that
We're about to do it, it's about to start though.
No see I feel like i'm gonna fall off a lot so I'm just gonna drink when ever I'm getting lifted up.
Oh shit..
*screaming*
I'm gonna go we can't all have the same strategy.
Ow that hurts.
This game suddenly got way hard.
Ohhhh
150cc is really fast
*screaming* *shriek*
I'm doing like way good right now, way good.
See this is a hard time to drink because do we do it when you're in last place? Or do you do it when you're in first?
I thought there'd be like more rules to this game like when you drink, but I guess it's really up to you as a player.
I think it's meant to keep the game kinda pure.
How much did you drink Cody?
I finished the beer.
Oh my god!
Awww man
Ah I don't feel good though.
Oh you just passed me.
Now it's just Mario Kart, man... Now it's just Mario Kart
Yeeaaahh buddy.
Eat my banana!
Did you finish your beer?
Yes I did! Yes I did!
I just won!
Wait you cheated? How did you cheat?
Wait he's still drinking?
Wait that's against the rules. That means you lost.
I just won the race without drinking the beer
Huuuh!
I was finished having beer. *laughter*
Reviews of the game? I mean it's a classic game with twists.
I mean any excuse to play Mario Kart.
Yeah I would definitely play again this is pretty great.
Mario Kart gets you drunk quick!
I think we should figure out a way to do battle.
Yeah, I'm all about battle mode.
Yeah battle mode is the best.
Maybe each of your balloons is like a shot, and you have like three shots in front of you.
Lets set that up right now you know you want to.
You LOST! Arh and you're an adult!